digamos que tengo un conjunto de
vectores y déjenme llamarle a ese
conjunto el conjunto b y digamos que los
vectores que se encuentran en este
conjunto son de uno sobre dos y así
sucesivamente hasta ver acá ok entonces
vamos a suponer algunas cosas
interesantes vamos a darle algunas
propiedades muy particulares a este a
este conjunto y el primero de ellos
vamos a suponer que todos los vectores
que se encuentran en este conjunto
tienen norma o tamaño 1
ok quiere decir escribiéndolo bien
quiere decir que la norma o el tamaño de
cada uno de ellos es 1 y esto significa
que es esto vale para todos los vectores
b y dónde y puede ser desde 1 2
y no escribirlo bien puede ser 12 así
todos hasta acá ok pero si de hecho su
enorme es 1 también podemos suponer de
hecho no podemos suponer se concluye que
su norma al cuadrado es decir si
elevamos la normal bueno si elevamos al
cuadrado de ambos lados debe ser también
uno pero quién es la norma al cuadrado
la norma al cuadrado es b y punto b y
verdad la norma al cuadrado se define
como el producto punto de un vector
consigo mismo y esto es válido para
perdón esto es igual a uno para iu desde
uno hasta acá ok entonces estas son tres
formas equivalentes de decir que tiene
tamaño 1 y que nos van a ser bastante
útiles cuando cuando estemos trabajando
en este vídeo si lo escribimos en
palabras que a veces se entiende mejor
quiere decir que todos los vectores
todos los vectores
debe tienen
tienen normas
1 ok son unitarios entonces también una
forma de decirle a esta propiedad es
decir que todos los vectores todos los
vectores han sido normalizados o que han
sido
y la palabra es normalizados ok esto es
decir que todos los vectores que se
encuentran en b tienen norma 1 ok ahora
otra cosa interesante que vamos a
ponerle como propiedad a este conjunto b
es decir que todos los vectores son
ortogonales entre sí y esto esto se
escribe de una forma muy particular
quiere decir que si yo hago el producto
punto debe y con bj ok esto me va a dar
0 si si si tomamos vectores distintos
verdad porque si tomáramos vectores
iguales estaríamos diciendo por ejemplo
b y punto b y eso sabemos que es 1 pero
si tomamos vectores distintos de este
conjunto b por ejemplo porque tomemos b
1 y b 7 o qué sé yo y hacemos el
producto punto eso nos va a dar 0
entonces esto de aquí se puede escribir
como que todos
todos los vectores todos los vectores
son y dijimos que la palabra es
ortogonales ortogonales
entre sí ok es decir que si yo me tomo
cualesquiera dos vectores y hago el
producto punto de ellos eso me tiene que
dar 0 siempre que me haya tomado dos
vectores distintos verdad entonces para
recopilar esta información y esta otra
información
lo podemos escribir de la siguiente
forma si yo me tomo dos vectores debe de
de mi conjunto b b y punto
bj
tiene dos posibilidades o es cero o es
uno cuando es cero cuando en realidad
estamos tomando dos vectores distintos
es decir que el subíndice estos
subíndice son distintos y que significa
que son dos vectores distintos y es uno
si en realidad no me tomé dos distintos
es decir me tomé el producto punto de un
vector consigo mismo ok entonces aquí
está resumido todo esto que hemos dicho
y el ahí hay un nombre particular para
un conjunto de vectores que tiene esta
propiedad y entonces decimos que b es un
conjunto es un conjunto corto normal
y la palabra es que es un conjunto orton
normal y el [ __ ] pues claramente viene
de que es un conjunto ortogonal es decir
los vectores son ortogonales entre sí 2
a 2 y el normal viene de que está de que
todos los vectores son normalizados es
decir que tienen norma 1 ahora una
propiedad la primera propiedad muy
interesante y que es bastante útil de
este tipo de conjuntos y que vamos a
demostrar es que b se puede concluir que
ve es linealmente independiente
linealmente independiente
independiente y recordemos que este
concepto es muy importante para todas
las cuestiones de a la hora de construir
bases de espacios vectoriales verdad
entonces cómo vamos vamos a demostrar
que es linealmente independiente
entonces tenemos aquí todo nuestro
conjunto todo nuestro conjunto de
vectores ok y la definición de que sea
linealmente independiente desde que si
nos tomamos una combinación lineal de
todos ellos es decir si nos tomamos por
ejemplo
si nos tomamos una combinación lineal
digamos c 1 por b b1
uno más de dos por dos más muchos de
éstos
por beca y nos das el vector cero la
única forma si el conjunto linealmente
independiente la única solución posible
para que esto ocurra es si las
constantes c1 c2 y todas estas se hasta
seca son necesariamente cero aquí en
principio todos los seis aunque si son
números reales verdad son números reales
para allí desde uno hasta acá verdad
entonces si tenemos nosotros una
combinación lineal tenemos que demostrar
que cada uno de estos de estas dos de
estas constantes se y tienen que ser
cero y aquí vamos a utilizar muchísimo
la propiedad de que el conjunto es es
ortogonal entonces vamos a utilizar lo
siguiente si yo a éste vamos a hacerlo
con amarillo
si yo de este lado hago producto punto
con cualquier b vamos a llamarle b r ok
si me tomo cualquiera de los que se
encuentren aquí ok cualquiera de los que
se encuentran en el conjunto b y hago un
producto punto entonces también del otro
lado tengo que hacer producto punto para
que se mantenga la igualdad ok pero
fíjense muy bien esto si lo
desarrollamos es ver bueno aquí primero
hacemos el producto punto de este con
éste sacamos la constante y nos queda
hace 1
vr punto b 1 +
c 2 de r
punto b 2 así sumamos hasta que en este
en esta suma encontramos el término
relacionado con ere y nos queda
punto b r verdad en algún en algún lugar
está el br en esta suma correcto
entonces nos tocará encontrarnos con
este este término y así no seguimos
hasta que llegamos a seca y nos queda
ver punto b acá y esto es igual a cero
punto ver que no es otra cosa más que 0
muy bien entonces si nos damos cuenta
que ya son números reales y como ve como
son ortogonales es decir si nos tomamos
subíndices distintos estos todos estos
todos estos me tienen que dar 0 excepto
uno y cuál va a ser pues justamente en
donde me tome a br br porque si son
iguales dijimos que si los subíndices
coinciden esto me debe dar 1 muy bien y
entonces si todos estos son 0 lo único
que me queda sería cr x br punto de r
que dijimos que esto es 1 y esto es
igual a cero por lo tanto
por lo tanto cr es igual a 0 pero
fíjense que aquí nos tomamos cualquier
vector de r verdad hicimos el producto
punto con cualquiera el que ustedes al
que ustedes más les guste de este
conjunto entonces no importa cual
subíndice nos tomamos esto es cierto
para er 12 hasta acá entonces todas las
constantes son 0 gracias a que es un
conjunto ortogonal y por lo tanto es
linealmente independiente ok entonces si
esto es linealmente independiente
podemos concluir que ve este conjunto b
es una base es una base de un espacio
vectorial b y de hecho el espacio
vectorial b es el conjunto o perdón es
el espacio vectorial generado por pues
los vectores que se encuentran en vez
que dijimos que era b1 b2 así
sucesivamente hasta
muy bien entonces ahora como además el
conjunto ve que de hecho ya ya
entendieron por qué le puse de verdad de
base de hecho cómo es una base entonces
decimos que ve de esa base
orton normal corto normal
por todo normal de nuestro sub espacio
ve ok entonces ahora vamos a dar un unos
un ejemplo un ejemplo de cómo se ven o
cómo trabajar con los conjuntos
orton normales porque aquí está muy
abstracto y demás pero bueno vamos a
hacer un ejemplo
por ejemplo tomémonos primero el vector
de uno que tiene como coordenadas están
en r3 por cierto y tiene coordenadas un
tercio dos tercios y vamos a ponerle
aquí dos tercios entonces este es un
vector en r3 y vamos a tomarnos un
vector b 2 igual digamos que tenga
coordenadas dos tercios y un tercio y
menos dos tercios
muy bien entonces si nos consideramos el
conjunto b que tiene al vector b1 y b2
la pregunta es bueno este conjunto es
[ __ ] normal bueno vamos a ver primero
vamos a calcular la norma de estos
vectores entonces quien es la norma
digamos la norma al cuadrado desde uno y
siempre uso el cuadrado para que yo
pueda expresar lo como b 1 punto b 1
verdad y b 1 punto b 1 no es otra cosa
más que este al cuadrado más éste al
cuadrado más este otro al cuadrado
entonces es un tercio al cuadrado es un
noveno más dos tercios al cuadrado es
cuatro novenos más dos tercios al
cuadrado son cuatro novenos y que si lo
sumamos nos queda uno más cuatro son
cinco más cuatro son nueve novenos que
es uno entonces la norma debe uno es uno
entonces este vector de aquí si está
normalizado vamos a ver si ve dos
también está normalizado vamos a ver qué
ocurre con la norma de b 2
cuadrados y esto es de 2.2 que es dos
tercios al cuadrado son cuatro novenos
más un tercio al cuadrado es un noveno
más menos dos tercios al cuadrado que es
cuatro novenas que otra vez nos da uno y
por lo tanto la norma debe dos es uno
muy bien ahora este conjunto si es
ortogonal hasta ahorita falta perdón es
no está normalizado vamos a ver si es
ortogonal y eso es muy sencillo porque
nos tomamos simplemente el producto
punto de b1 con b 2 ok y entonces
hacemos un tercio por dos tercios esto
es dos tercios dos dos novenos perdón es
un tercio por dos tercios es uno por dos
y tres por tres
dos tercios por un tercio son dos
novenos nuevamente y dos tercios por
menos dos tercios es menos cuatro no
vemos que aquí tenemos cuatro novenos
menos cuatro novenos esto nos da cero y
por lo tanto concluimos que este
conjunto es un conjunto corto normal
conjunto
orton normal
es [ __ ] normal y de hecho podemos
garantizar que el espacio vectorial
generado por los vectores b1 y b2 está
dado de tal suerte que ve es una base es
una base corto normal [ __ ] normal de ese
espacio vectorial es una base [ __ ]
normal de nuestro espacio